I love short films short films have this
unique charm where the storytellers have
to get creative with the way their story
is presented as with the very limited
run time you have to make every single
second count and this is especially true
for animation films where every single
frame of animation is an opportunity to
add to your narrative in some way last
year we add amazing because of this I've
always been pleasantly surprised by the
amount of short films that have
emotionally impacted me more with a 5 to
10 minute runtime then some entire
series could ever achieve at all so when
I saw Portal Robinson's new passion
projects shelter a short film slash
music video animated by a-1 pictures
with music and collaboration with Maddie
on it certainly stood up there with a
small amount of anime short films that
have impacted me so before I go any
further in this video I'm just going to
tell you to watch shelter if you haven't
already it's only six minutes of your
life to just do it
oh oh wait Oh what do you have something
better to do is it that thing you know
that thing you always like to do look
this is a pg-13 channel so we don't even
need to say the words let's call it
having a shinji ikari do you feel like
having a Shinji Ikari right now look go
Shinji Ikari it's all out and then watch
the video and I'll still be here okay
[Music]
all right are we all Shinji carried out
good did you also watch shelter great go
wipe your tears and possibly also your
hand so we could talk about what a
fantastic job Porter Robinson and his
team did and yes I did think it was
fantastic to get that opinion out of the
way for those usual think this is
overrated which is only inevitable when
something small like this games as much
attention as it does now I'm not here to
break down and analyze the entire shorts
frame-by-frame as are plenty of other
youtubers who can probably do it better
than I ever could but also because
unlike other shorts like me me me the
story and overall message of shelter is
actually pretty simple to understand but
in case you missed it
shelter follows a story of a young goat
who's in some kind of virtual reality
where she seemingly has free reign over
this world via her magical iPad or is it
a Galaxy Note cell everything seems fine
and dandy I mean if I was a cute anime
go of literally the entire world at my
fingertips I'd probably spend all day
lounging around my bed too but
everything is turned on his head when
touching a lone swing triggers her PTSD
causing her Vietnam flashbacks to
resurface and would you know it it turns
out Jupiter got pissed at the earth one
day and decided to crash-land one who
cares about that look at this cute
little girl with a cute little smile yes
the same cuteness from dying along with
the rest of the world her loving father
built a spaceship with this virtual
world in it which he sends her off in
unknowingly triggering the reboots of
Supergirl and that's pretty much it
she's just flowing through space I guess
for how long who knows
possibly forever goodnight come on let's
get some despite all this a short even
manages to end on a positive message
showing us that our memories even our
most painful ones can be used as a
stepping-stone to move forward in the
future as a stronger person which is
nice you know it's always good and a
little positivity when alone girls
drifting through space forever when our
parents and possibly the whole of
mankind is dead well that that sounded
really bleak when you say it out loud
hey hey work you anime girls I'm alright
it's a very simple concept that place on
the core themes of fatherly love and
existentialism through complete
isolation of a 17 year old girl flying
through space but that's the beauty of a
shore like this it shines from its
simplicity as not a single frame is
wasted in presenting this idea to us
resulting in a master class of visual
storytelling even though the short has a
bit of dialogue in it we certainly don't
need it at all to understand what is
going on and the simplicity does not
detract from the impact of it in fact it
enhances it and it's this simple core
message that really sells it so
these petitions calling for full series
of this to be made it's just no it would
ruin the entire charm of the short
something like this says everything it
needs to in doesn't overstay its welcome
and that's what makes it special what's
great about shelter is that you can
sense the love and passion that went to
crafting it extra pops of mega mokona
for handling the character designs an
entire key animation because the
animation looks absolutely beautiful
throughout but most importantly you can
feel port Robertson's vision burning
through every frame of this this was his
passion project and you can tell his
passion resonated perfectly with the
team he was working with it's entirely
refreshing to see an anime that contains
a love for an entire medium from an
outsider who for all intents and
purposes has nothing to do with anime
whoa whoa whoa wait does this even count
as an anime hey let's uh let's see what
reddit have to say about this yes I
wanted to touch on a little debate that
happened when the video is first posted
on reddit our anime board where it got
removed we're not complying with the
specific definition of what anime is hey
what you trying to do you telling me
sponge or ban in anime makes you'll be
telling me I can't talk about hey Arnold
or Arthur you [ __ ] hack this video
was eventually put back up but I bring
this up not to troll an entire anime
board I are anime nice talk to you for
this gets removed but very the question
of whether this and all future projects
like this even count as real anime or
not and the honest-to-god answer is who
[ __ ] cares we live in an age where
the anime we grew up on and our fans of
have inspired people many people some
Japanese some Western some grew up to be
normal everyday people some grew up to
have opportunities in the creative
industry and some of these people will
have the power to express their love for
the medium in their own way which is why
I think small projects like this or
other collaborations could become more
common in the future and as they do the
line between what houses anime and what
doesn't we'll just get more and more
blogs as for example with the term otaku
has blurred vastly from its original
meaning especially here in the West
industries evolve and anime is no longer
just strictly a Japanese business the
audience is global and so are the
companies investing in it hell there are
even animators who aren't Japanese
working on anime so it doesn't matter if
it's anime anime collaborated animate
influenced this project and others like
it embodies what anime should be about
just creative people doing creative
things inspired by some works that are
familiar to all of us as anime fans not
some for gun debate about where it was
made who worked in it or who it was
targeted for Porter
Robinson has shown us that is possible
to live the we dream that a single
individual can Commission an anime
studio to make their own anime all you
really need is Fame a [ __ ] ton of cash
an international music producer vacuum
from some anime studios and companies
and a great vision with a burning
passion easy right
what we see here someone's love letter
to anime and it doesn't matter where he
came from he may just be a dumb weave
trying to show his love for a medium but
he's our dumb we tried to show his love
for a medium and that's something you
could feel losing out of every framing
shelter and it's something that
resonates with those of us who have
tried to show that same passion in our
own way so as a fellow anime fan who
also loves the medium I just have to say
great job Porter you did us proud
[Music]